George thanks for taking the time you're
an incredible guy fascinating guy George
and I got a chance to catch up earlier
uh and I think you guys are really going
to enjoy what he has to say so George
one of the things that we talked about
was just how you got started in business
and I found it fascinating because you
know when you were starting that
business in 1973 it's just very very
different from the way the businesses
were kind of started in San Francisco
Silicon Valley these days so you can you
tell us about a little bit about kind of
the founding of Men's Wearhouse and how
basically you started with seven
thousand dollars and a business plan
well sure Tom I had seven grand which
went for first and last ones rent so
that left us with a zero balance and
that's why the very first commercial
that Men's Wearhouse ever ran I was not
the spokesperson the tagline was the
only thing better than a friend in the
business is a father in the business and
I had a father who was able to arrange a
hundred thousand dollars of credit so
that I could actually have inventory
when I started yeah that's awesome so so
you got started seven thousand dollars
one hundred thousand dollars of
inventory how did you make that first
step towards finding customers and
starting to build the the mega brand
that you know Men's Wearhouse became
well of course the advertising
originally was just newspaper and then
it morphed into television and radio and
this was before there were pcs and
social media so this was the way to
develop a business and it was very
different than the business I'm starting
now in which you have to lay out the
entire business spend all the money
upfront and then hope that you were
right and you get customers yeah and and
the TV side of things is amazing because
you know I think I heard a stat that six
billion dollars went into kind of
promoting your face TV which is just
incredible how did you how did that
first TV buy come into existence can you
tell that story because I thought it was
just amazing
well my I had a friend who a new friend
and met him at a wedding in 1974 and he
was in the advertising business in New
York and talked to me about my startup
and and said you know maybe I ought to
look at putting the entire thirty-five
thousand dollar advertising budget on
television I said okay we'll do that
we made some commercials and they flew
down from New York and walked into our
store and said you don't have enough
inventory I'm going to delay the
commercials by 30 days so so you
immediately after taking your $35,000
marketing budget he says you have to
spend that much more on on inventory to
actually even be able to run the $35,000
TV buy exactly yeah that's incredible
so first TV ad goes out did it instantly
work was it where it was it the the boon
to your business that you were hoping it
would be well back in the mid-70s when
when this began there were in most
cities in the United States between
three and five television stations so
when you ran a television commercial you
were getting a huge audience so I would
say within three weeks of starting on
television the business started to pick
up and it basically continued that way
with a couple of minor interruptions for
the entire 40 years I was there and and
how did you evolve the brand from you
know nothing better than that they're
the only thing better than having a
friend in the business as a father in
the business - you're going to like the
way you look I guarantee
the end well the UH you may recall that
there was a movie in the 80s with Bill
Murray named stripes and he has this
famous line in the movie where he says
when asked if he's part of the United
States Army he says that's the fact jack
and I wanted to say that in an ad-lib at
the end of an early commercial I did and
realized that was inappropriate for
commercial TV so I quickly self edited
it to I guarantee it and then in the
late 90s a very smart television
director inserted the words you're going
to like the way you look in front of I
guarantee it and we thought that made it
even more powerful and how much of that
do you credit to your voice well the way
I look at advertising today is that
advertising is more about repetition and
consistency than it is creativity now
that may be changing as we move away
from TV and radio and into social media
but my voice up became what we used to
say was is that if somebody is in the
kitchen getting a snack and the
commercial comes on they're still going
to know it's a Men's Wearhouse
commercial even if they can't see it
yeah absolutely I mean that was the
voice that sold me my first suit so I
appreciate that
so so you mentioned kind of creative how
do you how do you see creatives role now
that you're running generation tucks and
you're relying a little bit more on
social media as opposed to the TV buys
that you had built Men's Warehouse on
well uh you know looking at for instance
your creative it's
it's fantastic and it presents for
relatively small dollars the opportunity
to create a very positive brand image so
I think there's a fantastic opportunity
today for young creatives in startups
but I still stick to that if you're
looking for scalability in business it's
hard to get away from television and
it's hard to get away from repetition
and advertising yeah I'm curious so so
in terms of like spikes in Men's
Wearhouse did you notice any big spikes
along the way I think there was at that
initial one but that were associated
with the branding or the content that
you were developing or just merely you
know repetition expansion well I hadn't
actually thought about that I'm sure
there were spikes but for the most part
it was a fairly steady upward slope that
menswear I was enjoyed for a long time I
mean up until 2013 certainly there was a
downturn during the Oh eight oh nine
recession there was a short down glitch
after 9/11 and for those that are old
enough to remember when Wall Street
dropped five hundred points in one day
in 1987 there are those types of one-off
problems but for the most part it was
really just running the same story over
and over until much like some of the
other iconic campaigns whether it's mr.
Whipple or tony the tiger or the
alka-seltzer man you you're not sure if
you're getting sick of the commercial or
actually starting to fall in love with
it but one or the other I think it works
equally well
and and so you know we talked about
creating a brand were you you know was
the brand that the men Men's Wearhouse
was a building was that very concerted
was that premeditated and you thought
this is the exact sentiment I want this
customer to have or did it kind of
naturally happen because you're a
charismatic guy and have that you know a
lust Riyaz voice that we can hear so
well well I'm not sure how to answer
that question I mean when I started
Men's Wearhouse I really was was was
going into business not to get rich but
because I wanted to be the architect of
my own life and I didn't want to have a
boss telling me what I had to do every
day or every week I think as the company
unfolded one of the things that made the
company successful was that it did
follow my own personality and and and
persona and and so we never had to
change our corporate culture or
corporate culture was from basically day
one the same until the day I was fired I
believe in the three years sins
the culture has probably diminished yeah
and you mentioned something interesting
when we were talking is is the mission
that you had in your advertising was not
to sway someone with emotion but rather
present the information and let the
customer make their own decision based
on the information that you presented
you know I'm not sure I'll tell this
story but I'm not sure that it's
actually right and the evidence would be
what you're doing now in your company is
is not about the rational side of life
it's about the emotional side that's
what your marketing is in most marketing
is thought to be better if it speaks to
the emotions and not to reason but when
I was becoming
the spokesperson for Men's Wearhouse I
wanted it to be based on unreason and
and not on emotion and so for instance
we never used sexuality or scantily clad
women as other clothing stores did to
sell merchandise we tried to make it
about facts and value and do you think
that that has something to do with the
product because you know business and
kind of you know business attire is
probably a little bit more rational a
little bit more concrete what we're
selling is a little bit just a little
bit more out there a little bit more
oriented towards the weekend which maybe
is a more emotional time you know I
think that it's more about the
difference between your generation and
mine I think that baby boomers like to
pride themself on a surplus of reason
and a shortage of emotion and I think
that your generation understands that it
doesn't have to be an either/or
proposition and that it's probably more
powerful to mark it with emotion so so
that kind of takes this to this
generation so you said kind of when you
started Men's Wearhouse it was getting
to get that freedom you wanted to be
your own boss now with Generation tucks
is that the same Drive or is it
something different no it's totally
different when you have had a successful
career for 40 years you don't have to
worry about being your own boss in your
second act
this is really about as it's evolved
about my legacy because I really would
like to number one be successful but I'd
also like to send the message to my
friends and family into the general
community that just because you're on
Medicare doesn't mean that you're not
capable of doing a start-up and so it's
it's it's actually
I wouldn't say it's as much fun the
second time around but it's close so so
you started one business in 73 one
business in 2015 is when you guys went
public there publicly launched how
different are these worlds of trying to
build a brand well you know since this
is a mostly younger audience I think one
of the biggest differences is that when
I started Men's Wearhouse there were no
computers to speak of so we had a manual
inventory control system that we created
which was with circles and in X through
the circle when the garment was sold if
you can imagine I ran the company for
close to a decade with that inventory
control system today obviously with Big
Data there is so much information
available that it really is not even
like talking about the same thing
anymore and how about like with the
advent of the internet and branding and
marketing how has that changed well you
know we never had to be aware of where
on our website we were losing traffic
right that didn't exist even when Men's
Wearhouse developed it a website in the
90s you back then you were not able to
look at page views and determine where
people were dropping out now with big
data you can get this incredibly
microscopic look at what your customers
are interested in and where you're
losing their interest so so speaking of
customers one of the things that you
talk a lot about is this notion of
conscious capitalism of thinking about
both the shareholders and the
stakeholders having an eye towards your
customers and your employees kind of fur
stand foremost and that's something that
I think is kind of tantamount to it is
just very important to success in kind
of today's companies can you explain a
little bit about kind of conscious
capitalism and and how you how you view
its role in business well in 1992 when
Men's Wearhouse went public and I went
to Wall Street to set it up and explain
my ideas on on I actually call it
stakeholder capitalism